what was your uh deciding factor on
getting sober like what was Rock Bottom
like for you you know it's weird I
didn't have a dramatic Rock Bottom uh I
mean okay
I did but it was every day you know it
was basically every day I would wake up
around four or five in the afternoon and
my first thought every single time I
woke up was disappointment that I hadn't
died in my sleep
because the night before I would like
take
as many things as I could to try and die
while I was asleep you know so I'd have
like 20 or 25 drinks two or three
hundred dollars worth of cocaine
whatever drugs were given to me and then
at nine o'clock in the morning handfuls
of Vicodin and Xanax and I was like why
won't I die I just wake up you're just
like God damn it yeah and I would get in
the shower at 5 PM just and just say
[__] like and I was saying [__] like I
felt sick I was so hungover but also
[__] why am I still alive so many people
would see that as being an example of
unmanageability for sure yeah but and
also just the hangovers and again I
don't know your guys experience but as I
got older the hangovers were so
bad like not just feeling sick but I
couldn't string sentences together I
couldn't think straight I couldn't like
you just felt like your brain and your
body had been possessed by all by just
weird chemicals and
so that that's why I had this thing
going on which I didn't actually you
know see as a reason to get sober like I
I would get such
terrible heartburn and that it would
wake me up I would be in like so much
like pain from the heartburn that I it
would wake me up I would go into the
bathroom and make myself vomit just all
this like horrendous bile and just acid
and then I would be able to go back to
sleep
maybe that's why I have the the
esophageal condition but rather than see
that as a sign to get sober I went and
talked to uh
to uh JP or jackass prop master I was
like man I guess it's heartburn it's
like
so bad and JP said I I had heartburn
really bad too and you know and then and
then I quit drinking and it totally went
away yeah and I looked at him said what
am I gonna do
my drugging out call the situation got
drastically worse and I was
like hearing voices like watching people
walk around who were never there it was
really like heavy psychosis
I don't want to distract from the story
but was that a result of specific drugs
because I always found PCP oh dude I had
great ones on PCP like I've I remember
one time in Denver
lying in a hotel room and there were
like 10 people standing around my bed
and I was like I I don't know if they're
real or not and I would close my eyes
like 10 minutes later open my eyes like
those same people are standing around my
bed and like oh yeah this is this is
angel dust this you know same people
showed up every time that when that one
night yeah like they just it was just
this group of 10 people standing around
the bed and like so it wasn't like a
shifting hallucination where it was like
oh it's my grandmother and now she's a
donkey it was like oh it's just some
random guy and nine other people
standing around my bed did you try
having conversations with these people
you thought I was a little scared of
them so I was like and I was also like
you know I don't I don't know if they're
real so maybe if I ignore them they'll
go away yeah they didn't because yeah
like drops sorry no go for it do you
think that like drops the veil of like a
dimension so they actually exist in
another dimension or is it just some
chemical going off of in your head I
personally have no idea I mean the
universe is such a complicated place so
it's like it could be
some other dimension it could be we
could be Holograms who I don't know the
truth of anything
um I do know that when I woke up in the
morning they were not there and there
was no evidence that these 10 people had
been in my hotel room yeah so in our
limited reality they didn't seem to have
much of a presence what about ketamine
for hallucinations ketamine is
pharmaceutical PCP yeah I I only ever
did ketamine in conjunction with 20
other things usually at five o'clock in
the morning and so like I don't even
know what kind of I've heard
ketamine is a phenomenal antidepressant
like it's a last stage antidepressant
for people with real clinical depression
I've also heard that if you inject it
the exact amount for your body weight
it's the most profound psychedelic drug
on the planet this guy Alexander shulkin
who was a chemist wrote about it
but mainly it's a rave drug you know
people would do it and they'd go into
these catatonic k-holes
that awesome
that's my favorite place to be so
um but okay so we're getting back to
Michelle Cho and not not eating mink
Burgers right yeah the what made me have
the most profound hallucin
hallucinations tactile You Know audio
hearing voices and you know seeing
people what was um
days into cocaine
Benders binging on cocaine for multiple
days while enhancing
nitrous oxide oh nice combo to the
exclusion of air as much as possible and
I would hold in the nitrous nitrous is
still one of the greatest drugs like and
the fact like it's also okay now maybe I
shouldn't even say this but I'm gonna in
the interest of full disclosure and like
we're only sick as our secrets there
have been a couple times in sobriety
when I've gone to have root canals done
and had nitrous
and it boy it's still great like I
didn't want to do more when it was done
I didn't like rush out to try and buy
more nitrous but I gotta say even in
sobriety a little nitrous high do I need
to start counting days again that's
that's what you call a free lap my
sponsor said that he was like he was
like did you take it as prescribed I was
like oh absolutely he's like and when it
was done did you run out to buy more
yeah no it didn't even cross my mind
he's like then enjoy it like you had you
had a free lapse yeah I you know your
dental work done without anything I've
never had nitrous in the dentist that
I'm aware of ever but you should with
the like the work the amount of [__]
yeah
um I I have looked forward to general
anesthesia in ways that creeped me out
that I felt that I needed to speak up
about with my home group
um but uh but in any case I had wild
hallucinations all kinds of stuff and
and I was so fascinated by the these
this phenomena that that's it was so
real and I do believe that that um the
the these substances somehow eroded the
barriers between dimensions and and and
sadly opened me up to
very low frequency kind of stuff I mean
there's different ways to kind of open
yourself up to higher frequency drugs
pretty low frequency so I had a lot of
demon activity going on and I that I
hallucinated like full interventions
where 10 people showed up to tell me
that they were worried about me and they
were never there
um and you were having conversations
with these people I was having all kinds
of conversations yeah with people and
and voices and and all that and so I I
just felt that I was privy to like other
dimensional entity activity and so
fascinated by it that I I just took to
the internet and searched like Spirits
spiritual you know like I just wanted to
get some kind of an understanding of
what I was privy to do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude